if you went back in time a hundred years
or so you'd see a lot of people doing
jobs that
don't exist anymore since most homes
didn't have refrigeration
milk men deliver dairy to your doorstep
every morning
and had an affair with your wife if 50's
comedy is accurate
elevators were driven like street cars
which meant elevator operators had to be
trained to ensure
a smooth and precise ride for passengers
phone lines weren't automated so
switchboard operators were needed to
connect you to your party
even the bowling alley had a team of
manual pin setters
to prepare your next frame these jobs
may seem
quaint or even absurd by today's
standards but don't feel too superior
perhaps a hundred years from now someone
will look back at your job and wonder
why you were necessary
[Music]
fear of technological unemployment is
nothing new
as far back as 350 bc aristotle
contemplated the idea of machines
performing human labor
during the industrial revolution textile
workers known as luddites destroyed the
newfangled machinery at the factory
and the steel drive-in man of folklore
john henry
literally killed himself competing
against a steam-powered machine
in 1930 the famed economist john maynard
keynes took a more optimistic view of
the problem
predicting that automation and
technology would soon allow people to
work only
15 hours a week that would have been
nice
of course today we know that neither
keynes nor the luddites had it quite
right
technology has made us far more
productive but it seems there's still
plenty of work to be done most
economists argue that technology doesn't
so much eliminate jobs as
change them that the number of tasks
rendered obsolete
are more than made up for by new ones so
instead of
switchboard operators now we have cell
phone repairman
broadbent technicians and mobile app
developers
this may be cold comfort if you happen
to have spent half a lifetime becoming
the
fastest switchboard operator in the west
but if it's any consolation
there are plenty of other workers in the
same boat
automation has been changing
manufacturing and agriculture for some
time
we're used to seeing robots in factories
and on farms but
recently the machines have been
expanding their territory
automatic kiosks are replacing cashiers
and bank tellers
fast food companies are experimenting
with burger flipping robots
and one robocaller can disrupt as many
dinners as a whole floor of
telemarketers
thanks to advancements in artificial
intelligence self-driving vehicles are
quickly becoming a reality
putting at risk anyone who makes a
living behind the wheel of a cab
truck or bus amazon is even implementing
unmanned drones to deliver packages
basically
any job that involves repetitive
predictable tasks is ripe for automation
but the machines aren't just coming for
the blue collars clerical jobs are
getting automated as well
insurance underwriters and loan officers
who research an individual or company's
history and calculate a precise level of
risk
are being replaced by algorithms that
can crunch more data
faster and more accurately purchasing
agents who maintain a company's stock of
merchandise and equipment
are outperformed by computers that can
order track and invoice at a higher
volume
and lawyers with access to fast online
databases have
less need for paralegals and secretaries
even tax preparers and financial
advisors
are feeling the heat from apps and
websites that analyze a customer's
portfolio
and give custom guidance okay now this
is getting scary
so what jobs aren't threatened by
technology's pitiless advance
well no job is safe forever but if you
at least want to buy yourself some time
you can focus on new and burgeoning
industries
careers in genetics video game design
and social media marketing
have seen strong growth in recent years
alternative energy and sustainability
are also on the rise
and it's no coincidence that there's
high demand in the fields of robotics
and data science that's right you can
get a good job teaching robots and
algorithms to take other people's jobs
away
kidding not kidding another field that
seems to be safe for the time being is
the arts
some cutting-edge software companies are
developing ai that can write
poems draw pictures compose music even
design fashion and while they might be
impressive from a technological
standpoint
none of them are close to competing with
human artists
it may sometimes feel like franchise
movies and pop songs are written by
computers but i
assure you there are real people behind
them i think
so congratulations poets and musicians
you can now brag to your insurance
underwriter brother that you made
a better career decision however your
plumber cousin has got the better of
both of you
trades like plumbing electrical and hvac
are well paid
and fairly protected from automation
that's because they are
often unpredictable and machines do not
do well with unpredictability
these workers are called out to random
homes and businesses
asked to diagnose and fix unexpected
problems
robots have a long way to go before they
can match that kind of flexibility
but perhaps the most future proof jobs
in america are the ones that rely on
interpersonal interactions
social workers counselors occupational
therapists
clergy the more tact and compassion
required
the safer the job is from technological
replacement
even if a computer could understand the
complexities of human emotion
it still couldn't form the bonds of
trust and mutual respect that these
workers must forge with their clients
particularly in demand right now and for
the foreseeable future
is elderly care not only does the
profession require
a distinctly human touch america's
elderly population is quickly reaching
historic levels
we may be headed for a severe labor
shortage in this field
one that robots aren't ready to fill
neither humans
nor computers are too good at predicting
the future so
take all of this with a grain of salt
one thing
is certain though technology keeps
moving and
not much can stop it you may think you
have a cutting-edge job but
so did the elevator operator once the
best thing you can do to protect
yourself
is to pay attention to innovations in
your field and be ready to learn
new skills your job may someday get
taken over by a robot
but someone has to design that robot and
build it
and program it and maintain it and
supervise it
someone already in the field is in a
better position to take one of those new
jobs when the old one
goes the way of the milkman and that's
our two cents
quick before you go do you know what you
want to be when you grow up
no matter your answer we think you
should check out future of work
a new six-part docu-series on pbs voices
hosted by julia and me
that explores the real big work-related
questions that americans are facing
today
everything from debt and the gig economy
to career identity and so much more
check it out link in our description and
be sure to tell them that two cents
sent you thanks to our patrons for
keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become
a two cents patron
[Music]
you